divide escribe la respuesta como un
número mixto siempre que dividan algo
entre una fracción recuerden que esto es
lo mismo que multiplicarlo por su
recíproco es decir que esto es igual a
tres quintos por el recíproco de un
medio es dos entre uno o dos enteros y
ahora hacemos la multiplicación
numerador con numerador 3 por 2 es igual
a 6 entre denominador por denominador 5
por 156 puntos eso queda como una
fracción impropia pero nos piden que el
resultado esté como un número mixto para
esto dividimos el 6 entre el 5 y el
resultado será el entero y el residuo
será el numerador de la fracción hacemos
en 35 el 5 cada vez una vez en el 65 por
1 565 queda 1 por lo que esto como
fracción impropia de hecho marcó el
residuo con otro color para que se note
esto es igual a un entero un quinto y
así hemos terminado algo que no es obvio
ese porque esto funciona es multiplicar
por el recíproco a continuación haré
otro pequeño ejemplo para comprender
mejor esto si yo tomara cuatro objetos
234 y lo dividieron en grupos de 2 lo
divido entre 2 me va a quedar un grupo
de 2 y otro grupo de 2 me van a quedar
dos grupos de dos y ahora tomaré los
mismos cuatro objetos los mismos cuatro
objetos 1 2 3 4 pero ahora los dividir
en grupos de un medio entre un medio así
que aquí voy a tomar la mitad de cada
objeto y voy a hacer un grupo con cada
mitad 1 2 3 bueno la mitad donde está se
denomina exacta pero imaginen que eso es
exactamente la mitad del objeto
8 así que 4 entre un medio va a ser
igual a 8 si se fijan cada objeto se
transformó en dos grupos así que cada
uno de estos cuatro objetos se
transformó en dos grupos 4 por 2 8 esto
es igual a 8 es la misma cantidad de la
misma respuesta que tenemos acá y espero
que esto les haya ayudado a comprender
mejor por qué es que esto funciona